bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo blog e io sono fa vj è come
al solito inizio ogni blog facendo
vedere una fan art che mi avete mandato
questa settimana la fan art che state
vedendo è di sharon stupenda secondo me
la prima che mi è stata fatta ha
disegnato a mano e non al computer e
comunque io l'accetto entrambe perché
sono veramente fantastiche cioè io tra
l'altro io faccio schifo a disegnare ve
ne accorgerete tra pochi giorni alle è
più avanti vi spiegherò perché nel blog
vabbè comunque ringrazio tantissimo
sharon per il disegno perché veramente
fantastico ok ragazzi devo dire
parecchie cose in questo blog quindi
cerco di stringere
come avrete letto sicuramente nel titolo
ho preso la partner con mascini ma dopo
un mese dall'apertura del canale è
veramente senza di voi non sarebbe stato
possibile ho voluto prenderlo ho voluto
prenda parte a con massima perché
diciamo sono già dentro ma cinema code
share e gaming da più di un anno da
circa un anno comunque quindi conoscendo
lo staff sono riuscito ad entrare ma
comunque senza di voi non sarei riuscito
lo stesso quindi voglio veramente
ringraziarvi
vi giuro vi ringrazio a tutti con tutto
il cuore se potessi vi stringerei la
mano ad uno ad uno solo che dato che
siete più di circa 3.300 adesso mi
farebbe un po male la mano però va bene
se potessi giuro lo farei
quindi veramente grazie per quello che
per questo regalo che mi avete fatto e
vi prometto che sarà mi farò divertire a
più non posso poi i prossimi video
soprattutto ne approfitto ragazzi per
scusarmi sei video gli ultimi due o tre
video di questa settimana erano un po
meno divertenti del solito però gli
ultimi due tre video registrati che
avevo più o meno la non la febbre ma
comunque avevo l'influenza e non stavo
meno bene del solito anche perché quando
registro video e prendo infatti non è
che sto bene lì mio però vabbè
già sono pazzo però con l'influenza
diciamo sono sono stati meno
coinvolgenti
diciamo quindi mi voglio scusare
soltanto per questo
ma con i prossimi state tranquilli che
ci sarà da divertirsi
comunque finalmente che dato che ho
preso la partner
adesso si vede lo sfondo del canale che
è rimasto uguale per un mese tutto blu
non si capiva niente quindi adesso se
cliccate su fa vj tv l'icona li fa
ricettivo che trovate sotto che è
entrata nel mio canale si vede il
background e finalmente dopo un mese ho
potuto mettere background decente come
potete vedere c'è il cappello di babbo
natale ormai tanto siamo quasi in estate
in altro può però non si vedeva prima
quindi adesso si vede è il background mi
è stato fatto da jack parte che è un
grafico nonché una persona fantastica
perché è veramente professionale
simpatico è veramente io voglio
ringraziarlo per perché ha sopportato
tutte le mie richieste appunto di del
background lo stresso continuamente
quindi voglio ringraziare tantissimo
jack e ragazzi se se siete interessati
alla grafica se gli piacciono le
grafiche commenta in generale perché le
fa anche commentari su battlefield call
of duty in generale passate sul suo
canale che vi lascio sotto in
descrizione perché veramente lui un
fenomeno
lo ringrazio veramente tantissimo perché
stupendo più grandi niente da dire
arriviamo al punto importante del luogo
ragazzi sto facendo 2 coppe la prima e
con trombon su call of duty e svendita
bis e trovate canali trombon sotto in
descrizione è uscito il primo video
se volete vederlo trovate sul suo canale
poi prossimo ovviamente sarà sul mio
quindi ragazzi passate dal suo canale
invece la seconda coop e quella con dido
che mi state chiedendo
da secoli che da quando abbiamo fatto
porta quindi tre o quattro mesi fa
allora ragazzi io e dio ci siamo messi
d'accordo questo video uscirà venerdì
quindi se di venerdì e giovedì oggi
quindi lo sto registrando primo c'era 20
quindi venerdì registreremo io ti do
dovremmo registrare ci siamo accordati
la coop
nuova la nuova serie che apriremo su sei
in 33 quindi a mio parere sarà un gioco
fantastico e sarà una coop fantastica
vedremo cosa uscirà fuori perché secondo
me sarà veramente happy comunque non
perdetevela niente vi lascio comunque
anche il suo canale in descrizioni che
si è messo che lo conoscete tutti e
quindi passate da entrambi i canali
perché ci sono le coop
per quanto riguarda i miei video ragazzi
mi dispiace di non aver messo nessuna
puntata di penombra nell'ultima
settimana forse le ultime due non mi
ricordo neanche comunque da un bel pezzo
e non metto la puntata di penombra e vi
avevo promesso con un sondaggio su
facebook che all'unanimità avete scelto
per fare perché io faccio episodi da
circa 20 30 minuti
per farmi perdonare del fatto che non ho
fatto video di penombra
ho registrato due episodi da 30 minuti
ciascuno fantastici questi veramente
epici perché veramente mi son cagato
addosso ma poi vedrete e niente li
metterò tra poco quindi diciamo che
tutto il tempo che abbiamo che ho perso
con penombra in quest'ultima settimana
lo recupera eletti in questo video
perché li ho fatti più lunghi anche per
finire prima penombra perché facendo
video più lunghi di penombra finirà
prima e penso di essere anche quasi alla
fine tra l'altro durerà ancora tipo tre
o quattro episodi credo vedremo non lo
so comunque questo per quanto riguarda
penombra amnesia the great war che una
custom storia invece di un mese ho
iniziato qualche giorno fa è lunghissima
e avevo intenzione di riuscire a
portarla a termine se riesco prima che
prima che esca amnesia 2 che uscirà
all'inizio di febbraio credo comunque
intorno a febbraio quando farò anche
scrive all'ansa limited quando uscirà
perché l'ho già pre acquistato quindi
appena uscirà farò la serie anche su
scribblenauts comunque al mese the great
work cercherò di finirlo nel caso non ci
riuscirò a farlo puntate molto più lunga
e anche di questo di trenta magari anche
40 minuti non lo so e niente così almeno
siamo contenti tutti cerco di
accontentare tutti staccandoci un po
dall'horror perché questa settimana ho
fatto tantissimi horror
passiamo diciamo alle sorprese
dall'essere nuove che vi ho promesso
perché appunto il regalo che mi avete
fatto con la partner
diciamo deciso di cambiarlo perché ho
deciso di fare video che mi avete
richiesto in tanti serie che mi avete
richiesto in tanti quindi non soltanto
un video e allora vi annuncio
innanzitutto va beh la coop con di dove
l'ho già detto che non l'avete chiesto
da secoli e va bene draw my thing draw
mai fingo già registrato primo episodio
con voi su facebook 5 di voi hanno
giocato con me non mi lee non so chi
perché si chiama tutti fa vj guest
quando partecipano una partita comunque
vi ringrazio perché siete stati
bravissimi e uscita una puntata a mio
parere esilarante quindi sarà un video
etico che uscirà credo sabato sabato
domenica ho spesso sabato comunque
dovrebbe uscire sabato e non perdetevelo
perché a mio parere è piccolo fatto con
nikiniki box del tsg perché con lui mi
diverto un casino quindi non perdetevelo
questo è diciamo l'inizio di una serie
che mi avete chiesto voi è la seconda
serie che mi avete chiesto è happy
wheels allora happy wings lo farò però
devo vedere come va due linee saputo se
vi piace quindi farò un episodio sicuro
poi vedrò se vi piace e vedrò di
continuarlo se c'e una serie che prende
anche perché ormai è già stata fatta da
tanti youtubers comunque è più in sé un
gioco che varia in ogni suo livello
quindi dipende
c'è chi può piacere a chi no adesso
vedremo comunque fanno un episodio più
avanti e vedremo se vi piace su motori
dreams ha avuto un successo esilarante
non non so come mai vabbè so come mai
perché lido come un idiota tra l'altro
mi sono trattenuto in una maniera che
non avete idea perché quando rido io
diciamo mi vergogno da solo quindi mi
sono trattenuto che la metà bastava
cercherò di non ridere a squarciagola
nei prossimi nei prossimi episodi
comunque lo porterà avanti perché vi è
piaciuto tantissimo e quindi perché non
dovrei farlo e come ultima cosa che poi
non è ultima perché poi ci sono altre
serie che usciranno adesso vedrò io
perché comunque ogni tanto mi prende un
lapsus dico a mi piace quel video game
ad ora ci apre una serie il giorno dopo
c'è già un video per dire quindi non
posso dirvi tutto anche perché ci sono
delle cose che farò che non so neanche
io adesso comunque per quanto riguarda
le serie nuove ho deciso su facebook
sulla pagina di facebook e trovate in
descrizione sempre avevo ripeto sempre
ma molti di voi ancora mi chiedono ma
qual è la tua pagina di facebook favi la
trovate sempre iscrizione va bene
comunque saltiamo
su facebook farà un sondaggio dei giochi
più richiesti da voi che mi avete
richiesto da da mesi
e voi sarete voi a scegliere tra quelli
quale o quali vedrò quali quali
videogame sono preso più voti magari
sceglierò i primi due i primi tre euro
soltanto primo non lo so vedrò comunque
tra quelli che prenderanno più voti tra
quelli che sceglierete voi sua pagina di
facebook sul sondaggio che farò il
videogioco che prenderà più voti di
sicuro lo farò quindi sarete voi a
scegliere la serie e quindi niente se
volete partecipare al sondaggio mettete
mi piace alla pagina di facebook e non
lo troverete subito e lo farò in questi
giorni comunque allora quei progetti per
quanto ne so io adesso abbiamo finito
credo di sicuro mi sto dimenticando
qualcosa come sempre però vabbè
proseguiamo a ragazzi volevo dirvi
questa cosa che va beh è una chicca fra
virgolette prova ho scaricato razzo il
razzo al sicily comincia così
praticamente è un gioco dove bisogna
indovinare le parole fantastico nei
tempi morti ogni tanto mi diverto a fare
qualche partita è niente se volete
giocare con me basse ma sarebbero
scaricati si scrive rooms
niente a scrivere fa vj nei
negli amici da cercare mi trovate
comunque imitate mia qualche partita io
parteciperò e vedrete quanto sono scarso
comunque va bene se volete giocare come
fatelo perché tanto ci metto tre ore a
trovare una partita nuova ogni volta
quindi se mi date voi faccio prima
questa diciamo a vantaggio anche mio
però va bene se volete giocare mi
trovate sono fa vj come nickname
anche per quanto riguarda di instagram
ormai tanto lo dico perché è mio profilo
di instagram è andato a [ __ ] perché
ormai l'hanno scoperta scoperto mezzo
mondo va beh su instagram sono fa vj
quindi chi mi cerca mi trova con un come
fa vj va bè ragazzi prima di passare
alle domande volevo farvi notare
soltanto una cosa anzi volevo precisare
una cosa che voi mi avete fatto notare
molti di voi mi hanno scritto
ultimamente fa vj come mai questo nuovo
taglio di capelli
allora io non mi taglio i capelli da non
mi ricordo da quanto tempo comunque sono
passati dei mesi e non ho intenzione di
tagliarmi e lì semplicemente con le
nuove cuffie dato che ce l'ho sempre
addosso perché non me le tolgo che ho
dei capelli osceni a mio parere comunque
già così si vedono che sono tanti le
cuffie schiacciandomi già sono grosse
abbastanza come cuffie schiacciandomi di
sembra che sembra che sono di meno ma
sono semplicemente più schiacciati
quindi per quelli di voi che mi fanno
notare che mi sono tagliato i capelli
non me li sono tagliati semplicemente le
cuffie schiacciandomi di sembra che sono
di meno ma non sono di meno
assolutamente però è una precisazione
così almeno
così almeno smentisco le voci che non mi
sono piegato i capelli vabbè appunto
come in ogni blog arriva al momento in
cui risponde alle vostre domande ricordo
che se volete farne qualcuna scrivetela
qui sotto nel log qui sotto su youtube è
niente se tra quelle che farete nel
scegliere alcune risponderò nel prossimo
video in genere rispondo praticamente
quasi a tutte quelle che mi fate
comunque se volete farmi la domanda
scrivete da qui sotto è rispondere al
prossimo video la prima domanda arriva
da flavia che mi chiede fa vj guardando
l'ultimo blog mi è venuta in mente una
domanda come mai iniziato a fare
commentari e perché principalmente di
giochi horror spero di ricevere presso
una risposta allora bella domanda
innanzitutto per il fatto che è
difficile dare una risposta perché non
c'è una vera propria motivazione
comunque va beh per i commentari ho
iniziato un anno e mezzo fa un 9 e mezzo
un po troppo un annetto fa circa sul the
shared gaming con nichi box ei puffo
avevamo iniziato semplicemente perché
nichi box seguiva diversi youtubers io
ne seguì un po meno perché non ho mai
seguito commentare in generale però
abbiamo detto ma proviamo per quanto
riguarda invece il genere horror
a me piace loro in generale mi piace
prendere i corpi perché
diciamo adoro i film horror quest'estate
me ne sono guardati ma minimo minimo una
ventina una trentina tutti i giorni
tutti i pomeriggi con le serrande
abbassate si sono un pazzo maniaco
però mi piace un casino il genere horror
sia per quanto riguarda i videogames sia
per quanto riguarda i film la terza
domanda arriva da bari bomber e nome
epico domanda blog
hai un corpo allora non ve l'avevo detto
comunque allora no non ho un corpo
perché praticamente oltre questo punto
qui che vedete qua non so non ho nulla
prima è il mio corpo è costituito
soltanto dal torso in su quindi no non
ho un corpo glowing ce l'ho fatta la vj
come si chiama la canzone è quella di
sottofondo penso che intenda ps se in
granda dalla ringrazio per il
complimento
la canzone che senti in sottofondo che
sentiti in sottofondo diciamo non è una
sola ma sono tante e niente sono
ovviamente vi lascio il rilascio in
descrizione titolo di quella principale
quella con cui apro e chiudo ai blog
sempre è la stessa che usa anche più di
sì però sono stato il primo ad
utilizzarla quindi non vedo perché se
l'ho utilizzato anche lui dopo io devo
toglierla no al massimo la leva lui che
vuole comunque ripeto il titolo trovate
nella descrizione ed alle sino avanti
dunque nei blog lo metterò sempre yagami
kira l mi chiede favi senti scusa per il
linguaggio dove cazzo è comprato that's
not allora il death note
questo
l'ho preso su ebay circa un mesetto fa e
basta che si basta che scrivete su ebay
death note notebook lo trovate
[Musica]
e niente l'ho preso perché sono un fan
sfegatato di death note che il mio animo
è preferito mi piace un casino gli anni
me ne guardo sempre tanti ha tra l'altro
mi sono ricordato adesso voglio
ringraziare di cuore chi di voi mi ha
consigliato di vedere acer world
c'è stato un periodo in cui è finito di
vedere sgarlato online
volevo iniziare una trani ma non sapevo
quale inizierà loro chiesto a voi sulla
pagina di facebook e ragazzi con la
scelta unanime carino uno di voi mi ha
consigliato acer guarda ho iniziato a
vedere arce world chi è stato ci vorrei
fare un monumento perché me lo sono
visto tutto ed è fantastico
a mio parere forse anche un po meglio
this guardato mai ma questi sono gusti
tanto e fatto dallo stesso autore
comunque per quanto riguarda il death
note l'ho comprato su ebay
adesso che me l'hai chiesto dovrò per
forza scrivere il tuo nome perché perché
niente adesso probabilmente tu cercherai
di uccidermi quando lo comprerà i vabbè
raga chiudo qui con le domande perché
sennò dura mezz'ora solo questo blog
prima di chiudere ragazzi mi sono
ricordato che devo salutare dover
salutare caterina e libia che sono due
ragazze che che ho incontrato che mi
hanno riconosciuto come ho detto non
scorso blog mi hanno cecchinato mi hanno
riconosciuto e mi ha detto ma se fa vj
si è allora sono obbligato a salutarvi
nel log però dall'ultima volta che ho
salutato qualcuno ne in un mio blog è
uscito fuori
nei blog nei commenti di quel blog
50.000 persone che mi chiedevano di
essere salutate ragazzi non posso
salutare tutti siete in tremila e
qualcosa se dovessimo andare tutti
dovrei fare 500 blog sono di saluti e
quindi saluto chi chi mi incontra ma se
continua così allora penso che da questo
luogo in avanti in assoluto più nessuno
comunque va beh un saluto a loro due è
basta ok ragazzi vlog finisce qui per
chiudere mi avete detto che mi sto
dimenticando di tutti i video di
chiudere col telecomando come avevo
fatto vedere nello scorso blog che poi
non è un blog e non semi blog ma vabbè
non ho più chiuso col telecomando
semplicemente perché mi si erano
scaricate le pile e infatti come potete
vedere non funziona però adesso cambierò
le pile per questa chiusura sarà la mia
chiusura ufficiale di ogni video quindi
adesso cambio secondo le pile è in ogni
video state tranquilli che chiudono così
per chi ci tiene quindi nel frattempo vi
saluto
se vi è piaciuto video lasciato mi piace
se non siete ancora i siti iscrivetevi
lasciato il viaggio anche la pagina di
facebook per partecipare i sondaggi ai
futuri episodi di dro my thing e di
tutti gli altri consigli che vi chiedo
se volete la pagina trovate in ogni
video in descrizione e lasciate un
commento che le domande volete che
faccia che volete a cui rispondere
persona login niente ci vediamo prossimo
video
ok bella ragazzi